NARRATOR: Kitty O'Neil has
been overcoming adversity
for her entire life,
starting with a major setback
when she was only
three years old.
NARRATOR: In 1970, Kitty raced
a motorcycle in the Baja 1000.
Through her off-road exploits,
she met legendary Hollywood
stunt man Hal Needham.
Needham had taken up
directing, overseeing
the smash hit "Smokey
and the Bandit,"
but stunts remained
his first love,
and he got Kitty
into the business.
She was in many movies,
including "Blues Brothers,"
"Smokey and the Bandit."
She actually was the stunt
double for Wonder Woman--
Lynda Carter's Wonder Woman.
I think it'd be a
seamless transition
to go from being a
stuntwoman to land
speed racing because you need
that same amount of just crazy.
Kitty could drive just
about anything, fearlessly.
NARRATOR: That fearlessness
would lead her to a land speed
project put together by stunt
designer Bill Frederick, who
built a three-wheeled hydrogen
peroxide-powered rocket
car called the SMI Motivator.
On December 6th, 1976, at
the Alvord Desert in Oregon,
Kitty strapped into the
Motivator looking to surpass
the women's land speed record.
The mark of 308.56
miles per hour
had been set in 1965
by Lee Breedlove,
wife of legendary land
speed racer Craig Breedlove.
Her to go after that record
definitely took a lot of guts.
NARRATOR: Kitty achieved
an incredible average
of 512 miles per hour using
only 60% of the vehicle's power.
Kitty now had her sights set
on the overall speed record.
That latest mark had been set
in 1970 by Gary Gabelich, a test
subject for the Apollo
astronaut missions,
who had driven a
rocket-powered car to a mark
of 622.407 miles per hour.
Unfortunately for Kitty,
she was only meant
to break the women's record.
The overall record was
promised to her old friend
Hal Needham, who had paid
25 grand for the honor.
She was about to become,
literally, the world
land speed record holder.
She was this close.
She was almost there.
And they said, nope.
And they pulled
her out of the car,
and she didn't get to
set the next record.
NARRATOR: Perhaps as an
act of karmic retribution,
the weather turned,
making the track
unsuitable for Hal's attempt
before he arrived to make it.
Refusing to be silenced,
Kitty set two different kinds
of speed records in 1977.
In June, she drove the fastest
quarter mile in history
in 3.22 seconds, hitting a top
speed of 412 miles per hour.
In August, she piloted a boat to
a speed of 275 miles per hour,
becoming the fastest
woman on the water.
Kitty retired from the
speed record game in 1982
after leaving a lasting mark
on the sport and the world.